there's every reason to think that
physics provides the underlying
fundamental laws that describe how mind
works that's the working hypothesis that
Francis Crick calls the astonishing
hypothesis that I think basically every
serious neurophysiologist assumes that
by understanding at a molecular level
how nerve cells worked and understanding
at an architectural level how they're
wired together and understanding the
logic of the processing as you might
understand how a computer works that
that will give a rich and in a sense
complete understanding of how the brain
works that there's nothing missing
that program is very very far from being
accomplished and so it's logically
possible that something will go wrong
but so far it doesn't that seems to be
on track and they don't seem to be any
showstoppers as far as I can tell the
previous history is that at one time
people thought that there would be some
kind of special animism or vital
principle that was necessary to
understand how metabolism works or to
understand how heredity works or to
understand how other basic biological
processes work but in those cases I
think it's fair to say that we've
actually achieved a molecular
understanding it's not absolutely
complete but it's I think the conceptual
outlines are quite clear of how
metabolism works and how heredity works
and it is firmly based on the principles
of physics now that being said there's a
very important concept that as I've the
deeper I've studied the more I've come
to appreciate that Niels Bohr introduced
called complementarity
this in quantum mechanics is a theorem
but I think it has much more general
applicability it's the concept that
there can be an underlying reality that
you address questions to in different
ways that are meaningful and give
informative answers but require
processing the underlying reality in
different ways so that the ways that the
ways that you have to do the processing
might be mutually incompatible in
quantum mechanics that's just something
that's a theorem a mathematical theorem
that if you want to know where a
particle is you have to process its most
basic reality its wavefunction in one
way if you want to know how fast it's
moving its velocity or momentum you have
to process the wavefunction in a
different way and you can do either one
of those and get good answers for where
it's gonna be or how it's gonna move but
you can't do both at once because the
kind of processing that's involved is
incompatible I think that's a much more
general phenomenon that when you try to
address the nature of things you may
find that asking different questions
requires different ways of processing
the underlying information structures
the underlying reality so that for
instance in understanding human mind
which is what we were talking about to
understand it physically requires one
kind of processing and there's every
reason to think that we already have the
fundamental physical laws that are
adequate to that kind of treatment but
to understand how a person works how
thought processes moods and so forth add
up to a personality and a human actor
will require quite different ways of
understanding in quite different ways of
processing the underlying information
structure that that are probably
incompatible so the age-old conflict
between
Turman ISM and freewill for instance I
think is superficial there are different
ways of processing that could easily be
and apparently are incompatible if we're
dealing with our own experience or if
we're dealing with issues of law we
really need the product they fit the
concept of free will but if we're
dealing with the brain as a physical
object I think we can rely on the
physical laws